talks a lot about believing in his guys
especially the starting lineup one
Championship not too long ago having
patience letting guys kind of you know
find their game how aware are you of
that kind of patience and and how much
do you know do you value
it what do you want me to bench me no no
no it's like that's want bench
wigs I don't think I said that okay I
mean you can suggest it it's
fine but I mean thanks Steve I guess
like I don't know sometimes you earn
these things like patience and time to
find yourself and I think history will
uh is on our side when it comes to that
stuff you say that do you have you heard
people say that or is no I don't care
what people say like they don't do what
we do they can't do what they do that's
why they talk why would I like come
on I don't care what people say this
point in my life huh